figaro live il est 14h30 4 nous sommes
en direct bienvenue qui dans birds ou de
johnny depp sortira vainqueur du procès
qui agite l'amérique depuis un mois sans
doute véritablement aucun des deux et
une question l'actrice est elle vraiment
la grande méchante les fans ont
clairement choisi leur camp mais ce ne
sont pas les fans qui choisissait la
justice on va en parler et la réalité
est loin d'être d'être simple n'est-ce
pas un club friedman bonjour
journalistes à madame figaro vous
suivait très attentivement ce qui se
passe à fairfax en virginie
c'est là que se déroule le procès j'en
profite je montre c'est le madame figaro
spécial cannes avec léa seydoux
évidemment vous pouvez vous le procurer
on parlera de cannes à la fin parce que
chez madame figaro il ya une grosse
semaine qui commence la semaine
prochaine avec le début du festival de
cannes tout et on a fait le point
c'était quoi il ya deux semaines à peu
près il ya plein de nouvelles choses à
dire on précise qu'il ya une pause d'une
semaine n'y a pas eu de débat depuis le
début de la semaine tout à fait parce
que la juge qui est en charge du procès
avait prévenu à l'avant ce qui aurait
une coupure d'une semaine en raison
d'une conférence à laquelle elle doit
assister c'est d'accord bon donc elle
n'est pas là donc et bien ce procès a
été ajourné petite pause on reprend
lundi alors que les deux premières
semaines c'est johnny depp qui parlait
désormais c'est amber heard qui
s'expriment 1 devant devant la justice
quelle attitude prend l on sait que je
n'y vais plus il était plutôt rigolo il
essayait de faire rire la cour notamment
une était très détendu c'est pas tout à
fait le cas pour elle alors johnny depp
effectivement était très décontractée ce
n'est pas du tout le cas dans leurs
cordes ll était pleurer voir effondrée
elle tente quand même de garder sa
dignité mais là elle est assez assertive
quand elle évoque ce que lui aurait fait
subir johnny depp
mais certainement beaucoup plus dans
l'émotion beaucoup moins détendu que
johnny depp vous pouvez agir évidemment
sur lefigaro.fr sur tweets sur youtube
je salue théo je salue trillard clan je
salue patricia bienvenus n'hésitez pas à
vous poser toute vocation on essaye
d'avancer ensemble pour en savoir un peu
plus sur sur cette histoire
il ya une vague de soutien énorme pour
pour johnny depp avec ses propos sa
manière d'agir on ne parlera évidemment
de sa popularité mais est ce que l
embarras tu peux retourner l'opinion en
aignan et un côté un peu plus éplorées
et bien pour l'instant ça semble pas
être le cas puisque comme on en parlait
la dernière fois le hashtag tik tok
justice
est de plus en plus regardez là on en
est actuellement à 10 milliards de
personnes qui attaquent sur tic tac
assure tictoc d'accord donc
le hashtag en faveur du johnny depp qui
est très suivi il ya également du
merchandising qui est très surprenant
notamment 7 6 qui vend des t-shirts pro
johnny depp et des eaux la fac amber
heard notamment
et sur effectivement tous les réseaux
sociaux la majorité des personnes sont
en faveur d'une jeune d'ap maintenant
dans les médias après le témoignage
d'amber heard à la barre c'est vrai que
les médias ont un peu tenté de tempérer
notamment the guardian qui parle
des d'une attitude assez toxique de la
part des fans quand on entend notamment
des accusations graves qui sont portées
par amber heard on va y revenir
évidemment sur sur cette popularité est
ce que subit mine de rien bird allez on
rentre dans ce qui s'est dit là la
semaine dernière je vous propose de
l'écouter amber heard elle parle de
l'amour de sa vie ça a été la la grande
phrase très entendus la semaine dernière
écouter
et me
voilà ça c'est la grande phrase qu'on
retient de la semaine dernière des
premières prises de parole dans bird
tout à fait elle disait qu' elle ne
voulait pas à l'époque quitté johnny
depp elle voulait simplement qui la nuit
qu'il a eu lieu en raison de ses
multiples addictions donc face au
tribunal adoptent cette attitude
effectivement assez éplorée tandis que
johnny depp lui contrairement à son
attitude du début où il était très
décontractée ils rigolaient énormément
lui évite son regard il garde la tête
baissée parfois il parle avec ses
avocats mais il est beaucoup moins dans
la démonstration qu'il ne l'était
auparavant ce qu'elle veut paraître plus
humaine que lui ne les envoient par
exemple sur ces images il écoute il
sourit il rigole même on souvient
racontez moi ils riaient de ce que
disait de procureurs français très
étonnant par rapport à l on a vraiment
si j'ose dire une salle mais une salle
deux ambiances il ya un véritable
contraste on se souvient notamment de
johnny depp dans la salle d'audience qui
faisait des blagues qui disait ne pas se
souvenir de ses films avant pirates des
caraïbes qui s'était alice au pays des
merveilles mais aucun autre parce qu'ils
disaient qu'ils ne regardaient pas ses
films et ça les fait rire toute la salle
la juge avait dit qu'elle
avait menacé la salle de suspendre
l'audience et de la faire sortir si
jamais johnny depp continuer un peu ses
pitreries et la salle à en rire
donc on voit clairement un contraste par
rapport aux témoignages dans bird qui
lui suscite beaucoup plus d'émotions qui
lui est beaucoup plus poignant elle
essaie de rester dans la dignité mais on
voit quelle peine vraiment à
raconter ce qu'il s'est passé si vous
nous rejoignez les 14h40 nous sommes en
direct nous faisons un point alors qu'il
reste une semaine ça recommence lundi
dans ce procès entre johnny depp et
amber heard et on se pose la question
est elle vraiment la grande méchante on
va essayer de développer tous à vous
poser vos questions sur youtube sur
lefigaro.fr sur twitter on y répond
alors c'est vrai de l'extérieur ce
procès peut paraître de rien assez
amusant de starsky ce qui déballent
leurs leur vie mais des moments qui font
beaucoup moins sourire la violence la
violence conjugale notamment je vais
vous faire écouter cet extrait dans le
barde c'était également la semaine
dernière et là aussi c'est extrêmement
poignant
il a dit qu'il allait me meut défiguré
alors ça elle parle de cette fameuse
histoire en australie explique et moi on
avait eu la semaine dernière la semaine
d'avant là là les explications de johnny
depp que s'est il passé rappelez moi
cette histoire là qui visiblement
cristallise un tout à fait en fait il
était johnny depp en tournage en
australie à ce moment là donc c'était en
et amber heard et vite avec lui ils ont
une grosse dispute en raison du contrat
prénuptial que devait signer amber heard
en fait il s'avère que l'un des avocats
de johnny depp serait venu voir amber
heard elle aurait trouvé son
comportement aller à son égard déplacer
et ça aurait engendré une dispute avec
johnny depp une dispute durant laquelle
johnny depp raconte que son doigt a été
sectionné parce que en barreur lui
aurait de colère lancé une bouteille de
vodka et que ça aurait sectionné un bout
de son majeur que le majordome aurait
ensuite retrouvés sous le barre et c'est
un peu glauque désolé mais ce sont les
faits du procès il ya beaucoup de
détails sordides dans cette affaire et
et johnny depp aurait par la suite alors
là on rentre encore plus dans le sordide
écrit sur les murs avec son sens des
messages à l'attention de amber heard
oui et en baroeul raconte elle-même sa
version de l'histoire cette fois en dix
ans que l'acteur l'a attrapée à la gorge
la menacer avec cette bouteille cassée
et qu'elle a subi une agression sexuelle
avec la bouteille brisée oui ce sens
elle parle même du soleil c'est la
bouteille brisée mais en tout cas elle
avait peur que ce soit la bouteille
brisée oui elle explique que pardon pour
les détails mais c'est malheureusement
c'est ce qu'elle raconte est ce qu'elle
a raconté la semaine dernière lors et
pénétrait avec une de ses bouteilles
cette bouteille l'a peut-être on parle
même de viol alors là ce serait un viol
en l'état mais ce n'est pas un procès
pour viol c'est ça qu'il faut expliquer
c'est un procès pour diffamation
tout à fait c'est un procès pour
diffamation jeunes étape avait porté
plainte contre elle pour diffamation en
2019 elle même avait contre attaqué avec
une demande reconventionnelle donc lui
demander et 50 millions de dollars elle
dont elle en demande 100 millions voilà
donc c'est ça qui est tranché c'est une
question diffamation c'est pas vraiment
s qui l'a frappé est-ce qu'elle l'a
frappé non là c'est vraiment une
question de diffamation qui est traité
dans ce procès alors ça compte quand
même parce que si les jurés et signe que
la violence envers amber heard a eu lieu
au moins une fois
si les faits ont été avérés au moins une
fois
johnny depp perdra son procès à huy donc
c'est très intéressant très important de
savoir si une fois il y a eu ce genre
d'acte de la part de johnny da vous ne
réagissez vous n'hésitez pas je vous lis
un tout de suite sur youtube on a ce
clivage timber team john y voilà sylvain
qui nous dit qu'ils arrivent à ressentir
quelque chose lors de son témoignage
c'est tellement sûr jouer alors ça ça
m'intéresse il ya même eu
sur les réseaux sociaux des rumeurs des
rumeurs comme quoi elle aurait essayé de
rejouer une scène d'un film le
talentueux monsieur ripley cécile me
souviens bien dans une de ses
déclarations qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire elle elle fait du plagiat
de texte pour parler c'est ça alors ça
ça vient du compte twitter d'une
journaliste d'un site qui s'appelle
bright bartz est un site américain
d'extrême droite elle même il faut bien
savoir d'où ça vient c'est important de
le signer c'est important d'avoir la
source de cette information et la
journaliste sur son compte twitter a
donc publié des extraits vidéo de
l'audience de dan byrd ainsi que des
extraits vidéo de certains fine et elle
a prétendu que amber heard s'était
attribué les citations et les sites et
les situations de certains fine et même
de série parce qu'elle parle également
de la série made de netflix
durant ce procès donc qu'elle aurait
effectivement sur jouer ses réactions et
se serait inspiré d'autres situations
décrites dans des films je lis ce que
nous dit jumaa sur lefigaro.fr on a les
enregistrements c'est faux la version
qu'elle raconte alors oui c'est vrai
qu'on a eu des enregistrements dans
l'est dans les semaines précédentes qui
ont pas forcément tous démenti
ce que ce qu'elle disait ce que disait
amber heard tiens chloé jeu abandonné
personne sur le bord de la route ce qui
a les connaisseurs ceux qui le suivent
au jour le jour 1 ce qui nous écrivent
très vite timber timber ni mais il ya
ceux qui ne comprennent pas tous qu'ils
ne savent pas forcément ce qui est ce
procès ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
d'où sa part
alors tout commence donc en 2009 sur le
tournage de rhum express c'est là que en
d'horreur de rencontre johnny depp donc
c'est un peu le coup de foudre
d'après amber heard ils ont qu une
liaison
parce que johnny depp était à l'époque
marié à
vanessa paradis et ils ont officialisé
leur relation en 2012 d'accord et
seulement birds c'est en 2013 corps et
débuter les violences conjugales
en raison sa part d'une simple raison
c'est le tatouage de l'acteur c'est à
dire qu'elle est oui alors expliquez moi
cette histoire de tatouages parce que
c'est un peu lunaire quand on y pense
comme ça complètement c'est un tatouage
en fait qu'ils disent est à l'origine
winona ryder forever alors que winona
ryder ce qu'il faut quand même expliqué
alors oui nanard hc l'ex compagne ne
vous inquiétez pas si vous ne comprenez
pas tout moi aussi j'ai dû me
concentrais pour pour tout savoir mais
que vous explique ça très bien donc
winona ryder donc winona ryder c'est
l'ex compagne de johnny depp ils ont eu
une brève relation
est donc johnny depp c'était à l'époque
fait faire un tatouage winona forever
qui l'a depuis transformée en we know
forever donc ou wine ou en anglais ses
vins c'est un tatouage un peu décalé et
quand amber heard a posé des questions
sur le tatouage
elle affirme que
johnny depp l'aurait mal pris parce
qu'elle d'abord elle en rit elle trouve
ça assez décalé et lui aurait pris ça
comme de la moquerie et l'aurait giflée
et la corée débuté les violences
conjugales et il aurait par la suite
giflé à plusieurs reprises durant cet
échange donc on commence avec ce premier
de ce premier événement il l'aurait
giflée et ensuite c'est l'escaladé ils
se réconcilient un moment il se
réconcilie tout à fait il se finance en
2014 et ils se marient en février 2015
donc dans un contexte quand même très
tendu lily rose depp la fille de johnny
depp et vanessa paradis ou vanessa
paradis tout à fait n'est pas présente
au mariage johnny depp dit que c'est en
raison de tensions avec sa belle-mère
d'accord donc on voit que le climat
n'est quand même pas au beau fixe entre
eux et et il ya cette histoire
évidemment de contrat prénuptial
et de cette dispute violente et deux
doigts sectionnés qui prouvent ce climat
tendu on en est là donc ils se marient
mais climat tendu les années passent et
puis ils finissent par se séparer tout à
fait en mai 2016 hexacore amber heard
demande le divorce elle demande en même
temps une ordonnance rixte et
restrictive et dépose plainte pour
violences conjugales
donc elle obtient l autre sans
ordonnance restrictive
mais elle retire sa plainte pour
violences conjugales d'accord parce qu
en août 2016 en fait tous deux arrivent
à un accord commun
dont celle ci trouve un accord dé johnny
depp lui donne 7 millions d'euros c'est
ça tout à fait 7 millions de dollars
dollars oui voilà évidemment will 7
millions de dollars et doivent être
reversés 1 c'est ça à une association
caritative
tout à fait elle promet de reverser la
somme à plusieurs associations
caritatives dont une association qui
lutte contre les violences conjugales et
en soutien les victimes sauf que johnny
depp ce soutien lui qu'elle n'a jamais
verser ces sommes aux associations
d'accord donc on en est là ils se sont
séparés j'ose dire presse tout est bien
qui finit bien ils se sont mis d'accord
il lui a versé 7 millions elle doit
reverser cette union une association
caritative l'histoire est finie
théoriquement à ce moment là
théoriquement oui parce que le divorce
est prononcé finalisée en janvier 2010
est donc on n'aurait plus dû entendre
parler de cette histoire oui mais mais
le sun décide de publier un article dans
lequel
il qualifie johnny depp de mari violent
cette fois johnny depp décide de ne
réagir directement il porte plainte pour
différents mais diffamation contre le
sun donc c'est un procès qui se déroule
en 2020 et dans lequel on retrouve
beaucoup des immeubles déjà eu un procès
qui est quasiment similaire à celui l'un
exactement on retrouve énormément
d'éléments du procès actuel énormément
de preuves qui sont montrés dans ce
procès actuel au cours du procès de 2018
est donc ce procès à londres a lieu mais
avant cela il y à une tribune si je
comprends bien dans bird dans le
washington post donc on est avant ce
procès de deux milles marins exactement
alors en décembre 2018 en baroque publié
une tribune dans le washington post
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le procès
se tient à fairfax en virginie c'est
parce que le washington post est imprimé
là-bas et amber heard
se présentent dans cette tribune comme
une victime de violences conjugales
alors il ne cite pas johnny depp
mais alors son nom n'est jamais n'est
jamais prononcé vous me confirmer dans
ce truc jamais prononcée dans cette
tribune néanmoins johnny depp estime que
c'est assez parlant pour déposer plainte
donc il dépose plainte contre amber
heard en diffamation et réclame 50
millions de dollars de dommages et
intérêts
et c'est le procès qui se tient
actuellement amber heard contre attaque
elle en déposant une demande
reconventionnelle et en réclamant 100
millions de dollars voilà vous avez tous
les éléments pour recontextualiser bien
comprendre ce procès bien comprendre
tout ce qu'on vient de raconter avant
sur la dernière semaine je récapitule
johnny depp a parlé pendant presque deux
semaines c'est ça depuis le 11 avril
dernier et puis la semaine dernière
c'est amber heard qui s'est exprimé pour
la première fois attitude très
différente entre johnny depp et amber
heard lille était beaucoup plus
goguenard peut-être taquin provocateur
très serein elle souvent en pleurs à la
barre lorsqu'elle devait lorsqu'elle
devait s'exprimer pause cette semaine
pourquoi parce que la juge à une
concurrente aer voilà c'est ça donc
pause et on reprend lundi pour la
dernière semaine
on est au point alors on reprend entre
planches dans ce qui s'est dit la
semaine dernière j'ai lu que c'était une
audience très haché 1 les avocats ont
beaucoup interrompu tout à fait des deux
côtés ça s'est passé des deux côtés les
avocats de johnny depp comme sedan mme
bird ont formulé beaucoup d'objections
c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent interrompre
en fait les les témoignages
pour faire cesser les dires de la
personne d'un qu'au moment où ils disent
objections bien sûr d'orange là on est
dans une série américaine ont noté
entendu objection votre honneur on est
complètement là dedans on est
complètement là dedans et notamment il
parle beaucoup d'un certain type
d'objection aux etats unis c'est un type
de d'objection donc cs dit qu'il fait
objection aux états unis d'accord mais
c'est un type d'objection
qui en fait est liée aux documents et
personnes invoqué dans le témoignage de
la personne qui s'exprime d'accord et
ses adjoints techniques d'evian tg c'est
donc on essaye de comprendre allez c'est
drôle ça c'est clair mais si amber heard
par exemple évoque un témoin ou un
document n'a pas été présentée à la cour
les avocats peuvent
dire objections d'accord donc on en est
là et les avocats il y en a une qui fait
tout particulièrement par les regarder
cet article c'est sûr madame figaro vous
pouvez le retrouver de léonie du trait
vote camille vazquez alors expliquez moi
c'est le personnage qui émergent dans ce
procès qui est elle alors c'est
l'avocate de johnny depp effectivement
elle et elle émerge un peu durant ce
procès parce que d'abord les internautes
donc c'est une rumeur qui a fait surface
ces derniers jours les internautes sur
type toc ont publié des vidéos et avance
que l aurait une relation avec johnny
depp voilà c'est ça la grande histoire
elle est en couple avec johnny depp ou
pas on a du mal à savoir alors selon tmz
nom est l'objet d'un rappel c'est le
grand média people où l'un des grands
médias tabloïd des états unis ou tout à
fait et on vend ça ça reste une source
anonyme qui leur a dit qu'effectivement
il n'y avait pas de relation amoureuse
entre johnny depp et son avocate mais
que au fil du procès il avait développé
des liens avec tous ses avocats et donc
que ce serait purement amicale et donc
c'est une avocate qui a reçu des prix
qui est très médiatisée aux états unis
c'est ça elle est très médiatisée
notamment parce que elle s'occupe de la
communication de crise
dans pas mal de procès elle officie dans
beaucoup de procès en diffamation
d'accord donc c'est sa spécialité j'ai
bien compris oui et elle est très forte
sur la gestion de la réputation de ses
clients alors je lis ce que me dit
isabelle nona sur youtube quand on a
plus de succès pour le cinéma il faut
bien trouver à se médiatiser pour gagner
de l'argent c'est une médiatisation
énorme
c'est vrai que ça c'est le travers de ce
procès c'est assez impressionnant aux
étasuniens c'est assez impressionnant
ceci dit pour l'instant il n'y a pas
forcément d'impact sur la carrière de
l'un ou de l'autre je ne devais pas
parce que lui il a quand même porté
plainte parce que justement il dit que
sa carrière est terminée à cause d'elle
alors à cause d'elle à cause de ces
accusations en tout cas oui tout à fait
alors lui effectivement qu'il l'a déjà
dit à la barre il considère qu'il a déjà
perdu ce procès notamment parce que sa
réputation était trop endommagée durant
ce procès est d'ailleurs il a été évincé
de des tournage de pirates des caraïbes
et des animaux fantastiques
notamment pirates des caraïbes après
juste après la tribune dans bird donc
pour lui il a déjà perdu
mais il doit jouer dans le prochain film
de maïwenn en france en france nous
abonde donc jeanne du baril alors c'est
peut-être pas la même envergure et les
mêmes salaires j'imagine que que les
animaux fantastiques par exemple pour
johnny depp c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'avec les grandes sagas
hollywoodiennes
en tout cas semble
ça ne semble pas être son créneau pour
le moment est alors en baroeul elle
continue à jouer dans des grands films
aquaman par exemple alors elle doit
jouer dans la suite d'aquaman d'accord
mais il ya déjà une pétition qui circule
en ligne et qui a recueilli près de 4
millions de signatures qui demandent l'
éviction dans bird d'aquaman de oui oui
on comprend bien pourquoi parce que il
ya un engouement médiatique fort autour
de ce procès et l'opinion a choisi son
camp manifestement en faveur de johnny
depp et c'est pour ça qu'on se pose la
question en beurre d'herbes est elle
vraiment la grande méchante vous
continuez à réagir il est 14 heures 57
nous sommes en direct je vois vous êtes
nombreux sur youtube à prendre position
à choisir votre camp sur le figaro.fr
sur tweets vous pouvez le faire aussi
alors on commence à voir des chiffres de
diffusion parce que c'est diffusé sur
internet et sur le câble aux états unien
ce procès en intégralité tout à fait il
ya trois chaînes qui diffusent en
continu et le procès de johnny depp et
dans birds
c'est extrêmement suivie de partout y
compris sur les réseaux sociaux
d'accord et en termes de on a enfin un
aperçu des audiences notamment lohan
'crime la chaîne a déclaré qu'il y avait
eu donc ça c'est sa date du 2 mai ces
estimations mais qu'il y avait eu plus
de 330 millions de téléspectateurs sur
le wan prime pour ce procès jusqu'ici ah
oui 330 millions sur sur ce procès pour
regarder ce qui se passe alors ça dure
toute la journée enfin c'est surtout la
journée où tout l'après-midi en tout cas
il arrive et on suit tout en intégralité
on va venir dans un instant à ce qui se
fait sur les réseaux sociaux vous mais
commençait à me parlait tout à l'heure
en début de ce live sur ces hashtag
c'est très impressionnant la différence
dans les hashtag de de soutien avant ça
je voudrais vous faire regarder une
une image c'est bien la sortie du procès
de johnny depp la sortie du procès d'une
des journées du procès dans birds
écoutez regardez la différence on
comprend très clairement que l'opinion
n'est n'est pas a très clairement choisi
son camp
c
[Applaudissements]
je
voilà la différence il est applaudi il
serre la main tous les policiers très
détendu il fait signe aux fans comme
s'il sortait d'une avant première et
elle allait siffler effectivement c'est
très impressionnant il ya même des fans
qui dépensent des fortunes en billets
d'avion en hôtel à pouvoir assister au
procès ou du moins attendre johnny depp
à la sortie du tribunal où il est
accueilli comme une rock-star on voit
des fans notamment déguisé dans johnny
depp avec des pancartes il ya même eu
une
fan qui arrivait avec ses lamas pour
soutenir johnny depp est pour lui
redonner un peu de baume au coeur il ya
un véritable engouement en tout cas pour
johnny depp caleb ian qui me dit sûr sur
youtube la meuf sont ces mots là m'a
fait plus détesté que les vrais
prédateurs comme einstein ou einstein ou
cosby le sexisme de notre société c'est
vrai que c'est pas un peu gênant alors
on peut prendre position de manière un
peu rigolote et dire oui fut bordeaux ni
date je suis pour amber heard temps un
malaise des états unis eau autour de ça
comment se positionnent les autres
vedettes les autres stars d'hollywood
dans cette histoire c'est un peu ce
qu'ont dénoncé les médias comme on en
parlait tout à l'heure notamment the
guardian cet aspect un petit peu toxique
de la manière dont est perçue la sphère
notamment par les nourris par les postes
des fans parce que c'est vrai que ça va
quand même assez loin voilà
les soutiens de johnny depp sont quand
même assez extrêmes ils vont jusqu'à
notamment la traiter de manipulatrice et
lorsqu elle s'essuie le nez avec un
mouchoir dans le tribunal à prétendre
qu'en fait est là elle a consommé de la
cocaïne à ce moment là donc c'est très
extrêmes et les médias américains
dénoncent fortement ça alors il ya des
hashtag évidemment sur les différents
réseaux sociaux vous les connaissez si
vous nous suivez sur sur lefigaro.fr sur
youtube surtout que vous savez ce que
sont des hashtag il ya une très grande
différence ils sont comptabilisés j'ai
lu vous m'avez dit minière plus de 10
milliards d'achats de hashtag pour
johnny depp et ses quelques millions à
peine pour en dehors d une vraie
différence une véritable différence
comme on disait tout à l'heure 10
milliards de de personnes qui ont suivi
le hashtag just is for gender
surtees top donc c'est quand même énorme
sur twitter c'est la même chose on voit
énormément de soutien de johnny depp a
très peu dans bird et lorsqu'on parle
dans le mirror ii c'est souvent pour
pour la calomnie alors j'ai vu le terme
stan culture est ce que vous avez vu est
ce que c est ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer ce que ça veut dire sondés
hashtag qui serait l'oeuvre de cette
stan culture qu'est ce que ça veut dire
alors l'ac thann culture ça vient en
fait d'une chanson d'eminem qui
s'appelle way qui est sorti en 2001 et
dans laquelle il évoque un fan obsédée
par lui donc l'ac thann culture s'est
nourrie par ses fans un peu on pourrait
dire obsessionnel de johnny depp par
exemple donc lancé hashtag pour soutenir
johnny depp voir pour calomnie
underworld il ya beaucoup de daix texte
petite amie d'aix silence et maris
femmes qui sont appelés pas forcément à
la barre mais ils sont appelés à
témoigner à donner leur avis est ce que
vous pouvez mois en dire plus on a parlé
des lots de masques par exemple du côté
de dans bird l'aurait été séquencé
d'elon musk elle a été financée d'elon
musk c'est même pas du conditionnel il
me semble et puis j'ai une idée qui
était même marié avec vanessa paradis on
va chercher dans le passé et les ex
viennent donner leur avis tout à fait
alors sa forme en espèce de gigantesque
brouhaha parce que ça faisant un peu de
tous les côtés du côté d'hambourg hurd
elon musk devait effectivement témoigner
et james franco doit témoigne aussi
d'accord elon musk au dernier moment a
décidé de ne pas témoigner mais johnny
depp et c'est de décrédibiliser en tout
cas c'était moins en disant quelque
amber heard a eu des liaisons avec eux
pendant qu'ils étaient ensemble
d'accords est du côté de johnny depp
durant le procès qu'il avait intenté au
sun
vanessa paradis et winona ryder
notamment s'étaient exprimés qui sont
des ex compagne de johnny depp s'était
exprimé en faveur de johnny depp devant
le tribunal donc là elles n'ont pas
témoigné dans le procès actuel mais
durant le procès précédents et javier
bardem il avait également apporté son
soutien alors pourquoi javier bardem
quel est le lien alors il a ils sont
très amis d'accord il avait tourné
ensemble donc notamment dans pirates des
caraïbes donc
voilà il a souhaité apporter son soutien
à l'acteur alors vous me faites la
transition parfaite chloé parce que on
va essayer de se projeter sur ce qui se
passe la semaine prochaine la semaine
prochaine c'est donc la dernière semaine
théoriquement de ce procès vous me
confirmer et doivent s'exprimer deux
personnes deux témoignages forts sont
attendus
d'abord la placer dans bird la soeur
dans barbe whitney henriquez c'est ça
oui c'est bien ce que je lis alors
est-ce que ça a un poids qu'est ce
qu'elle va dire et du côté de genève je
crois savoir qu'on n'est pas vraiment
inquiet sur ce témoignage là alors
whitney henriquez s'est donc une actrice
même si elle n'a pas alors y jouer que
dans un film qui est la soeur d'albert
hurd effectivement son son témoignage
peut avoir un poids parce que elle
aurait été témoin d'une agression
perpétrée par johnny depp à l'encontre
d'anders en tout cas d'une altercation
entre eux qui seraient survenus en mai
2016 d'accord et durant laquelle en
beurre hurd aurait réagi en frappant
johnny depp parce qu'il s'en prenait on
ne sait pas c'est verbalement ou
physiquement à sa soeur whitney donc
elle pourrait évoquer cet incident
mais les avocats de johnny depp
pourrait essayer de décrédibiliser ce
témoignage
parce que il ya une histoire selon
laquelle whitney et amber heard aurait
été vu en train de mimer un coup de
poing comme si en bon ordre faisait
semblant d'être agressée comme
s'entraîner à faire son travail et
simulation et de cette agression
finalement tout à fait d'accord et alors
je lis camborde dit c'est ma partenaire
de crime c'est forcément ça n'a pas
forcément les aidez amber heard de tenir
un tel propos alors ça ce sont des
propos qu'elle a tenus dans une
interview donnée au haut niveau de
reporter en 2018 ou effectivement elle
dit qu'elle est très proche de sa soeur
qu'elle son meilleur ami après
partnering prime c'est quand même un
terme à ces eaux usées aux etats unis
c'est vrai qu'on peut l'interpréter de
différentes façons mais on imagine
évidemment que les avocats de johnny
depp ne vont pas se faire prier pour
appuyer sur ce thème deux partenaires de
crime il y à une autre personne alors ça
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant encore
plus intéressant si j'ose dire parler
des ex alors c'est une autre ex elie
barking c'est une actrice elle avait
joué avec johnny depp dans las vegas
parano dans les années 90 ça c'est un
témoignage qui est très attendue parce
que c'est une ex qui ne témoignera pas
en faveur de johnny depp tout à fait en
fait elle a entretenu une relation assez
légère avec l'acteur s'était pas quelque
chose de de sérieux elle dit qu'il n'a
jamais été physiquement agressif n'est
abusif envers elle mais qu'il a quand
même été verbalement
insultant envers elle est également
qu'elle a été témoin d'une altercation
entre johnny depp et ses amis durant
laquelle elle a johnny depp a balancé
une bouteille de vin à travers la pièce
d forcément ça ça rappel d'histoire
qu'on évoquait au début en australie
avec cette fameuse bouteille pourra
trouver des similitudes là dedans tout à
fait ça pourrait jouer effectivement la
défaveur de jenny des hamburgers balle à
elle a besoin de témoins indépendants
c'est ce que je lis pour l'instant c'est
pas convaincant pour l'instant c'est
vrai que c'est difficile
quand on sait que les témoins sont quand
même des gens très proches dans mon
erreur
c'est quand même des témoins qui sont
j'ai fait des témoignages avec de
l'affect sur lesquels on a plus de mal à
s'appuyer évidemment pour la justice ça
termine ça se termine donc je dis j'ai
bien compris jeudi prochain va reprendre
lundi matin évidemment et on suivra ça
vous pouvez suivre sur le figaro live et
sur les papiers du madame sur
lefigaro.fr
l'avancée de ses délibérations alors
justement les délibérations jeudi ça
pourrait prendre un peu de temps on
n'aura pas les résultats je dis alors
nous rappelle les résultats jeudi parce
que les réquisitoire et plaidoiries sont
censés survenir le 27 mis d'accord ce
qui veut dire que l'élan 27 mai je
prends un calendrier que c'est quand le
27 mai oui c'est donc presque deux
semaines un peu plus de deux semaines
tout a fini vendredi dans deux semaines
et donc il y aura les réquisitoire et
plaidoiries et par la suite les
délibérations mais alors on ne sait pas
combien de temps vont durer les
délibérations donc on ne sait pas encore
exactement quand elles s'achèveront
d'accord bon alors on attend on suivra
évidemment tout ça je lis quand même
quelques-uns de vos messages je vois
qu'on a des gens qui choisissent leur
camp si on le regarde la justice n'aura
plus de justice ni de valeur à mes yeux
dans notre société voilà il est très
clairement choisi son camp et c'est vrai
que sur le chat de youtube beaucoup de
monde et bien se range du côté de johnny
depp merci que les frères van merci de
m'avoir accompagné merci de nous avoir
expliqué un tout c'est toutes ces
avancées ces dernières avancées du de ce
procès qui fascine c'est vrai qu'il fait
froid dans le dos parfois mais qui dit
évidemment quelque chose de notre
société avec avec ses délibérations on
continue de vous lire donc sur
lefigaro.fr à la rubrique madame
évidemment vous allez être très pris
l'un parce qu'il ya le festival de
cannes qui commence la semaine prochaine
d'ailleurs je leur montre la une de
madame figaro vous pouvez vous procurer
en kiosque c'est ici alors quel est le
programme qu'est-ce que vous avez faire
sur le sur le site alors c'est un
programme assez varié donc ce sera
autant sur le site que sur les réseaux
sociaux le festival dure du 17 au 28 mai
donc on va essayer d'avoir une
couverture assez large tant sur le site
que sur sur les réseaux effectivement
sur les réseaux sociaux on publie
beaucoup de vidéos d'acteurs et
d'actrices qui seront présents au
festival et sur notre site une
couverture assez élargie où on décrypte
notamment les montées des marches et
bien voilà vous savez tout je pense
qu'on ne verra ni johnny depp ni amber
heard évidemment sur ce festival de
cannes mais on ne sait jamais voilà
merci de nous avoir nous avoir suivis
merci d'avoir été avec moi chloé la
suite sur feel your life ses points de
vue c'est tout à l'heure à 18 heures
vincent romane est plein de sujets de la
politique évidemment avec avec macron
toujours cette question qui sera son
premier ministre c'est un autre sujet
que que le people on se retrouve très
vite sur filière live merci de nous
avoir suivis et à bientôt